ich weiß ja nicht wie es Ihnen geht aber
ich privat finde es könnte jetzt auch
ruhig mal eine Woche vergehen ohne dass
wir über Waffensysteme diskutieren kein
anderes Thema mehr und zwar völlig egal
wo du rein selbst ich behaupte das
deutsche Fernsehen
militarisiert sich quasi in
Lichtgeschwindigkeit ja eine Tatsache
unsere
ja unsere Talkshows klingen inzwischen
wie eine Runde panzerquartet damals auf
dem Schulhof und als nächstes fragt
wahrscheinlich Harry weinfort weil der
Preis ist heiß was ein Haubitze kostet
ich meine wir haben jetzt über Wochen
mühsam gelernt was den Leo vom Abrams
Panzer unterscheidet und jetzt geht's
plötzlich nur noch um Tornados und Mix
ich komme nicht mehr hinterher Debatte
und Kampfjet Lieferung Kampfjets Raketen
und U-Boote verpflicht Ja oder Nein
Debatte um Kampfjets Diskussion um die
Wehrpflicht noch mehr Waffen kommt jetzt
raketenkampf Flugzeuge u-bote die
Debatte um die Panzer ist akut
ja ja wir schicken ja panskämpfer und
das ist auch in Ordnung ich finde es
richtig aber was bitte soll diese
idiotische Wehrpflicht Debatte unsere
Bundeswehr braucht alles mögliche das
stimmt aber doch nicht mehr schlecht
gelaunte 18-Jährige die fragen ob es
hier WLAN gibt
trotzdem wir müssen überwerflicht reden
sagt das Sturmgeschütz der FDP Marie
Agnes Flag zimmermann
die Verteidigungsministerin der Herzen
wir sind noch die hat ja schon 2019
versucht Lutz van der Horst zu
rekrutieren haben sie gedient nein altes
Weichei
jetzt hier jeden Mann jede Frau könnte
sich das vorstellen jetzt noch mal ich
bin gut für den Volkssturm also wenn
nichts mehr reicht dann kommen Frauen 60
plus und dann Leute vor allen Dingen
Russen passt auch was Sache ist
ja gut oder schlecht gealtert der Clip
je nachdem wie man es betrachtet ganz
anderer Vorschlag meine Damen und Herren
könnten wir den jungen Leuten bevor wir
sie zum komisch schicken nicht
wenigstens noch eine anständige
Schulbildung verpassen zur Abwechslung
laut Lehrerverband erlebt Deutschland
gerade den schlimmsten Lehrermangel seit
50 Jahren herzlich Willkommen zu
die heute-show lässt zum Angriff für ein
Sondervermögen Bildung ja meine ich tot
Ernst wer 100 Milliarden für die
Bundeswehr verballert muss endlich auch
mehr in kinderhirne investieren wir
fordern heute die allgemeine lehrpflicht
ja und das ist so wie im Moment nicht
weitergeht erkennt nun nach nur wenigen
Jahrzehnten Lehrermangel auch die
Kultusministerkonferenz ihr sogenanntes
Expertengremium hat dazu gerade erst
einen ganzen Sack voll Knaller
Vorschläge rausgehauen
Unterstützung durch Quereinsteiger
Pensionäre und ausländisches Personal
ist nur ein Ratschlag der Experten
Lehrer könnten auch später in Rente
gehen mehr unterrichten und das vor
größeren Klassen
ja nee das macht den Job garantiert
attraktiver
wer möchte das nicht länger unterrichten
vor größeren Klassen ein träumchen
warum schafft man nicht erst mal mehr
Studienplätze fürs Lehramt es gibt
nämlich viel zu wenige weshalb zum
Beispiel der NC für grundschulmatte in
Berlin zuletzt bei 1,8 lag
nc1,8 und dann steht man vor der zweiten
Klasse und sagt malte hat fünf Äpfel
auch dieser Plan pensionierte Lehrer
zurückzuholen die sind doch heilfroh
dass sie da raus sind aus der Hölle
nachzulesen in den berühmten Bestseller
der Hundertjährige Lehrer der aus dem
Altenheim Fenster stieg und wieder in
seine alten Schule unterrichtete
Leute es muss was passieren die Qualität
unserer Bildung geht rapide in den
Keller
orange
Magnesium
Sorge ganz genau
weiß gar nicht warum sie lachen richtig
Marvin Magnesium steht im Periodensystem
direkt neben Cornetto Nuss ja
ach komm hat er
ich kann es nicht genau sagen aber
der Junge hat es wahrscheinlich
verwechselt mit brauner boa oder so ich
weiß
uns fehlen mindestens 40.000 Lehrer und
zwar konservativ geschätzt und die Party
wir noch haben die stöhnen unter anderem
über die ganzen Verwaltungsaufgaben die
ja zum Unterricht on top dazukommen plus
lernrückstände nach Corona plus
Inklusion etc und dann wundert man sich
das fast die Hälfte der Deutschen
Lehrkräfte schon mit reduzierter
Stundenzahl arbeitet fast die Hälfte
diesen Leuten empfiehlt die Kommission
übrigens jetzt anschneiden
achtsamkeitskurse für den Stressabbau
vielen Dank auch ein Viertel aller
angehenden Lehrer leiden wohl schon
unter Burnout Symptom der angehenden ja
und das passiert wohl ständig da geht's
schon Referendar am ersten Schultag hoch
motiviert in die Evelyn burdecki
Gesamtschule in Köln Chorweiler und
kommt aber in der ersten kleinen Pause
so wieder raus
verdammt ich habe deine Haut oh ist das
schlimm die meisten Vorschläge der
Experten haben nur eine Botschaft Lehrer
sollen gefälligst alleine die Fehler der
Politik ausbauen Frage wozu haben wir
eigentlich eine Kultusministerkonferenz
wenn die es nie schaffen bei ihrer
sogenannten Bedarfsplanung auszurechnen
wie viel Schulplätze und Lehrer
gebraucht werden die schaffen das nie es
ist doch kein Hexenwerk ich verstehe
nicht ich verstehe nicht Zahl der
Neugeborenen + 6 Jahre Feierabend
tatsächlich gibt es mehr als nur
Indizien dass die unsere Geburtenrate
absichtlich runterrechnen um weniger
Leute einstellen zu müssen was bleibt es
Mangelverwaltung in einigen
Bundesländern werden bestimmte Fächer
einfach nicht mehr gedotet auch eine
Lösung und in Sachsen ist man sogar noch
kreativer jetzt soll in Sachsen die vier
Tage Woche eingeführt werden ein Tag in
der Woche soll wegen Lehrermangels nur
noch als distanzunterricht stattfinden
genial so und jetzt raten Sie doch auch
Spaß einfach mal welcher Tag das werden
soll am Freitag
oder B Freitag richtig Freitag ja gut
fürs lange Wochenende aber schlecht für
die Fridays for future Kids die müssen
dann in Sachsen dann irgendeinem anderen
Tag fürs klimastreiken aber hilft ja
nichts ist auch improvisieren es ist
wirklich
es ist wo du hinguckst nur noch
Flickschusterei Markus Söder zum
Beispiel hat angekündigt er will
tausende neue Lehrer aus anderen
Bundesländern nach Bayern abwehren mit
seiner Kohle was
echt töte ist für sein Premium
Bundesland wovon ist aber insgesamt
nicht mehr Lehrer werden das kapiere ja
sogar ich und ich habe ihn NRW Abitur
gemacht
wir brauchen endlich frische Ideen
die Kultusministerkonferenz bittet um
ihre Mithilfe Deutschland leidet unter
viel zu vollen Klassen und hier kommen
Sie ins Spiel liebe Eltern nicht einfach
das nächste Kind zeugen einfach weil sie
gerade Bock drauf haben checken Sie
bitte vor dem Verkehr unsere Schulplatz
one-app sie zeigt Ihnen an ob in sechs
Jahren ein grundschulplatz frei ist
schade leider nein macht nichts
Fernsehen ist auch schön die Schulplatz
waren App ist rund um die Uhr aktiv und
wenn sie grün wird dann aber Rotlicht
bevor die Nachbarn noch den Zuschlag
bringen diese App wird Ihnen empfohlen
von der Koitus Ministerkonferenz
schlimme Bilder
man muss der Realität ins Auge sehen
tatsächlich wird unser Schulsystem nur
noch von sogenannten Quereinsteigern am
Laufen gehalten allein in Hessen sind
das bereits über 10.000 Quereinsteiger
in Brandenburg reicht neuerdings schon
ein Bachelor zum Unterrichten gott steh
uns allen bei und an mehreren Berliner
Schulen sind die voll ausgebildeten
Lehrer längst in der Unterzahl in Berlin
haben wir die besondere Situation dass
selbst die Quereinsteiger nicht mehr
ausreichend Quereinsteiger waren die die
wenigstens einfach der Berliner Schule
studiert haben jetzt haben wir
sogenannte Löffel da sind die Lehrkräfte
ohne von den lehrbewegung die haben
manchmal irgendwas studiert ja
Löffel
Löffel Lehrer ohne volle leerbefähigung
nicht zu verwechseln mit den hyopace
ohne nennenswerte Kenntnisse das sind
die Honks das völlig anders und damit
wir uns nicht missverstehen auch bei den
Quereinsteigern sind natürlich richtig
gute Leute dabei man muss sie aber
trotzdem ordentlich nach qualifizieren
was leider nicht überall passiert dieser
Lehrermangel ist eine absolute für ein
reiches Land für unsere kein Wunder dass
sich der ein oder andere pädagogisch
schon nach früher
sehendala z.B
Lehrer früher der Traumberuf deutsche
Studienräte waren Respektspersonen und
hatten das Gewaltmonopol im
Klassenzimmer eine wunderbare Zeit
richtig 39 ticketplantagen gleichzeitig
der Lärmpegel wäre in jeder Fabrik
gesetzlich verboten macht aber nichts
weil wegen meinem Tinnitus mehr
selbst das ständige Verletzungsrisiko
juckt mich nicht
ja das Bügeleisen geworfen
Bügeleisen dabei
auch dass wir immer noch nicht digital
sind
[Musik]
so what Scheißding
egal
steh ich komplett drüber warum weil ich
Alkoholiker bin ja ich trinke auch
Unterricht sollen die Bratzen ruhig
wissen was sie aus mir gemacht haben
aber in die burnout-klinik komme ich
trotzdem und zwar wegen der schlimmsten
Erfindung aller Zeiten der Eltern
whatsapp-gruppe
wer backt fürs Klassenfest die
laktosefreien Muffins warum hat sero nur
eine 1 Minus in Deutsch er ist
hochbegabt sie haben Thomas Mann nicht
richtig verstanden die Erde ist eine
Kugel Ansichtssache hier ein
interessanter Telegramm legen
der deutsche Lehrerverband fordert
whatsapp für Eltern sofort verbieten
bevor es zu spät ist
was haben wir heute gelernt Liebe Klasse
unsere Jugendlichen haben immer weniger
Unterricht dafür und jetzt kommt aber
offensichtlich mehr Zeit zum Rauchen ja
sie haben ganz richtig gehört die gute
alte Zigarette feiert ein Comeback nicht
zuletzt bei jüngeren Menschen
20 Jahre lang war der Trend rückläufig
das Rauchen gerade im öffentlichen Raum
war geradezu gesellschaftlich geächtet
und jetzt wird es anscheinend wieder
cool Mist waren es 2021 noch 8,7% unter
den 14 bis 17-Jährigen sind es nun schon
15,9 literberg Rauchen fast 200.000
Jugendliche mehr zeigt die aktuelle
debrastudie bitte kann doch nicht wahr
sein wie viele junge Raucher sind dazu
gekommen 200.000
ah ja danke Horst diese Debra Studie hat
übrigens mit einer relativ kleinen
Stichprobe gearbeitet aber Fakt ist der
Tabakkonsum steigt tatsächlich wieder an
nur warum warum ist das so Experten
vermuten es könnte auch mit den
corona-jahren zu tun haben klar wegen
einer schweren Lungenkrankheit mehr
rauchen das klingt schon mal schlüssig
andere Theorie in Filmen und Serien wird
wieder öfter gequält und moderne
Zigaretten enthalten leider Zusatzstoffe
die das Kratzen im Hals verhindern auch
nicht gut wir halten fest die Cannabis
Legalisierung tritt auf der Stelle bei
der Ampel aber für legale Drogen läuft
eigentlich supi sagt auch der neue
Drogenbeauftragte jeder Erwachsene
trinkt im Schnitt einen ganzen Eimer
reinen Alkohol im Jahr und raucht sage
und schreibe über 1000 Zigaretten
sorry ich habe gar nicht zugehört was
hat er gesagt
tausend Zigaretten ja und von den über
25-jährigen raucht wohl wieder mehr als
ein Drittel Kommentar Karl Lauterbach
wir müssen uns Maßnahmen für einen
besseren Jugendschutz überlegen ja sag
bloß Karl es ist richtig ja das ist
richtig
es ist halt in Deutschland immer noch zu
leicht an Zigaretten ranzukommen
tatsächlich gibt es in Europa wenig
Länder in denen der Verkauf von
Tabakprodukten so Lachs reguliert wird
wie bei uns doch noch landet Deutschland
im EU-weiten tabakkontrollranking
abgeschlagen auf den hintersten Plätzen
ne okay schlechter als Bulgarien aber
vor Serbien immerhin ne immerhin in den
meisten Nachbarländern werden die Kippen
in schmucklosen einheitspackungen
verkauft manchmal gelagert in
geschlossenen Räumen die nur auf
Nachfrage geöffnet werden es ist
möglicherweise keine schlechte Idee
angesichts der unglaublichen 97
Milliarden Euro die uns das Rauchen als
Gesellschaft jedes Jahr kostet hier
erschreckende Bilder vom Sportunterricht
an einer Kölner Realschule was haben sie
da unten in ihrem Stutzen drin
zu retten ja der Junge den wir gerade
gesehen haben ist übrigens erst 16
denken sie damals erschrecken
ja wir Deutschen lieben eben unsere
Verbrenner ob auf der Straße oder im
Mund ganz egal anderswo wird hart
durchgegriffen in Neuseeland zum
Beispiel kostet eine Packung Zigaretten
mehr als 20 Euro pro Packung und wer
nach dem ersten Januar 2009 geboren
wurde darf da gar nichts mit Tabak drin
kaufen moment mal der ergibt sich ja ein
völlig neuer Standortvorteil für
Deutschland ich sage wir müssen sofort
Werbung schalten in Neuseeland
New Zealand ist beautiful but very
boring everything is forbidden Sobo know
free weeks old Coaching smoking in
Germany mal the Lunge baumeln lassen es
we say you can by kippen everywhere in
the Edeka at the Kiosk oder Späti evened
night at the Automat or at the Tanke and
guess what the Tanke also sales Alkohol
und benuke
und our Autobahn also außerordende A1
natürlich Dennis always Baustelle
Germany
everything
stances you can't way you Altglas on the
Sunday oh you that's
Dressing land of the free home of the
Raucherbein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
man kann es auch als Marketing cool
sehen komm nach Deutschland zum
chainsmoking so aber jetzt kommen wir
zur entscheidenden Frage wie macht man
das Rauchen wieder weniger attraktiv wie
machen wir es wieder unattraktiv ich
sage ihnen ist ganz einfach wenn man
wirklich will dass die Kids Rauchen
uncool finden muss man als schockfoto
auf den Packungen einfach maximal
uncoole Leute beim Rauchen zeigen
das hier fast kein Teenager mehr an
meine Damen und Herren
tatsächlich führt der Weg zur Zigarette
wohl manchmal auch über ihre elektrische
Schwester die E-Zigarette vaping da
stehen die voll drauf die Teenies ja
wegen der ganzen süßen Aromen Problem
man weiß noch gar nicht was in den
verdampfenden Flüssigkeiten so alles
drin steckt bis zu 2.000 verschiedene
Inhaltsstoffe beim Welpen deren
Langzeitwirkung noch nicht erforscht ist
die Sorten klingen erst einmal harmlos
diese Kiwi die läuft sehr gut ja ist
total beliebt und dann gibt's
Wassermelone und äh verschiedene
Geschmäcker
wann kommt endlich der erste Schnuller
als vaper auf den Markt meine Damen und
Herren vielleicht sollte ich mich an
dieser Stelle mal persönlich an die Kids
vor den Geräten wenden in diesem
Influenza Style den Sie von Instagram
kennen
jo Digger du rauchst gerne Kiwi und was
haben Melone dann check mal den neuesten
Trend aus den USA mein Startup nennt
sich pass auf Real fruit ja wir
älteren nennen das Früchte
das geniale die riechen und schmecken
genauso wie deine lieblings Liquids fürs
Welpen aber the shit ist der behelfi
Alter ne und jetzt kommt der Burner du
kannst Mango Erdbeer und Apfel sogar
wild kombinieren das nennen wir dann
fruits
nice ja
der Vortrag hatte ja ordentlich Swag
meine Damen und Herren um Gottes Willen
und hey liebe klimaaktivisten also ich
rede jetzt ausdrücklich nur mit denen
die nicht gerade auf Bali Urlaub machen
Liebe klimaaktivisten wir für Klima und
Umwelt ist sollte überhaupt nicht Welten
bei den einen weg vapern schmeißt man
jedes mal die Batterie mit weg und
Rauchen geht schon gar nicht denn viele
Zigarettenfilter landen am Ende im Meer
ja Kinder denkt damals darüber nach ne
ja und es kann ja hunderte dauern bis
sie sich im Salzwasser zersetzen
Herstellung und Rauchen von Zigaretten
Liebe klima-retter verursachen jedes
Jahr 84 Millionen Tonnen CO2 fun fact am
Rande in Spanien oder Frankreich muss
die Tabakindustrie selber für die Kosten
der Verschmutzung durch ihre Produkte
aufkommen in Deutschland stellen wir
fest läuft es eigentlich ganz gut für
die wie genau haben die tabaklobbyisten
das geschafft ein Krimi und ein klarer
Fall für till Reiners
[Applaus]
CSI Tabak mit till Reiners
[Musik]
Weihnachten 2019 die Zigarettenindustrie
wünscht sich höhere Steuern auf ihre
kippen
bitte was ja der Clou die Steuern
sollten nur moderat angehoben werden
nicht so schnell und drastisch wie ein
Großbritannien wo viele vorstreck direkt
mit dem Rauchen aufgehört haben bei uns
kriegen die Lungenkrebs Produzenten
genau das Gesetz dass Sie bestellt haben
plus eine fette Steuererhöhung für die
E-Zigaretten Konkurrenz war halt
Weihnachten so aber wem haben wir das zu
verdanken gut dazu müsste man zunächst
herausfinden wer damals Finanzminister
war meine Profiler haben bereits ein
erstes Phantombild erstellt Zeugen
beschreiben
einen extrem farblosen Mann anfangen 60
mit den Hobbys abwarten abwägen und
Termine mit Bankern vergessen
sein Name reimt sich auf toller smolz
mehr wissen wir noch nicht oder
nein
schade was wir wissen sein Ministerium
hat sich damals 12 mal mit der
Zigarettenindustrie getroffen und genau
null mal mit Gesundheitsexperten die
Analyse unter dem
Elektronenmikroskop ergibt 12 mal das
ist genau 12
mehr als 0
[Musik]
die Frage ist warum bekommen
ausgerechnet wenige tabaklobbyisten so
oft und so schnell einen Termin bei Olaf
Scholz das ist jetzt das neue
deutschlandtempo bei spoke of the new
Deutschland Geschwindigkeit
dass die Wörter Deutschland und
Geschwindigkeit im selben Satz überhaupt
erlaubt sind Wahnsinn
Arbeitshypothese hängt der Kuschelkurs
für kippendreher vielleicht auch damit
zusammen dass die regelmäßig Partei Tage
Sommerpartys und spargelfahrten von SPD
und CDU Sponsoren und bleibt Deutschland
jetzt für immer ein Paradies
da
Olaf Ernte 23 Scholz der ist uns
wirklich immer einen Schritt voraus
weißt du was ich mache jetzt mal nur zum
Spaß eigentlich noch mal kann sich
Scholz vielleicht doch noch ein Treffen
mit tabaklobbyisten erinnern nein ja
selten war ich so überrascht an was kann
er sich nicht der Mann überhaupt noch
erinnern ich bin Olaf Scholz
immerhin das deckt sich auch mit unseren
Informationen dann würde ich mal sagen
guten Abend
ich glaube eh nicht dass das hier gerade
noch jemand sieht Wetten lieber heute
show-fans wenn ihr das hier noch seht
schreibt in die Kommentare Gernot
hassknechts schauspielerische Darbietung
hat mich zu Tränen gerührt und abonniert
gerne den Kanal danke
und die endcard macht ihr jetzt hinter
jedes Video klar auch wenn ich nicht
darin vorkomme